[Música]
la duma rusa ratificó los tratados de
anexión de donies gerson y saporiya a
Rusia además el kremlin declaró que el
uso de armas nucleares solo Sería
posible en caso de agresión contra el
estado ruso
el líder supremo de Irán el ayatolá
alija menei acusó a Estados Unidos y a
Israel de organizar las protestas por la
muerte de maxa la joven que falleció
tras ser arrestada por la policía de la
moral iraní y cuya muerte ha desatado
protestas masivas contra el régimen de
Teherán
en Estados Unidos iniciaron los alegatos
en el juicio contra cinco participantes
del asalto al Capitolio los acusados
pertenecen a la organización de extrema
derecha Oz y enfrentan cargos por
conspiración y sedición conectaremos con
Washington
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
mateu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos esta edición en Rusia porque
la duma la cámara de diputados ratificó
los tratados de anexión a la federación
rusa de las regiones de donesk lugans
gerson y saporiya además de los tratados
fueron remitidos a la duma los proyectos
de ley constitucional para el ingreso de
esos territorios al Estado ruso
recordemos que el pasado viernes
Vladimir Putin proclamó la anexión de
estas cuatro regiones tras un proceso de
consultas populares que occidente ha
calificado de farsa laurel nos amplía
una ley aprobada por unanimidad los
diputados de la duma a la cámara baja
del parlamento ruso votaron todos a
favor de la anexión de las regiones de
iTunes
ya ocupadas en parte o en su casi
totalidad por músculo una ley que según
el jefe de la diplomacia rusa protegería
la cultura y las fronteras de su país
Quiero unirme a este ambiente festivo y
felicitar al representantes de estas
cuatro regiones de la federación rusa
no estamos reaccionando ante amenazas
imaginarias en países lejanos
estamos defendiendo nuestras fronteras
nuestra patria
nuestro pueblo de un verdadero genocidio
organizado por los Sucesores de los
sacólitos nazis al servicio de Los Amos
de ultramar
el ministro de asuntos exteriores acusó
a Estados Unidos de haber según sus
palabras sometido a occidente y utilizar
a Ucrania como un instrumento de guerra
contra Moscú Y es que la mayoría de las
potencias o sigue condenando la anexión
de estas cuatro regiones
la fuerza de los referendos amañados
demuestra que Rusia se da cuenta de su
fragilidad y busca dar un barniz
democrático a sus ofensivas
no reconoceremos estos supuestos
referendos ni La anexión ilegal de
Vladimir Putin Esto no es más que una
provocación
Rusia inició la semana pasada al proceso
formal de anexión con el presidente de
firmando la ley junto a los líderes
prorrusos de las cuatro regiones pero
ninguna está totalmente bajo el control
de sus fuerzas y Ucrania ha ido
avanzando en sus contraofensivas en el
sur y el este del país
cambiamos de información el líder
supremo de Irán el ayatolá alija menay
se pronunció por primera vez respecto a
la muerte de maxa Amin
lamentó el incidente pero acusó a
Estados Unidos y a Israel de organizar
las protestas desatadas por la muerte de
la joven que desde hace más de dos
semanas tienen lugar dentro y fuera de
Irán
con la ira creciendo en todo Irán las
protestas lideradas principalmente por
mujeres no muestran signos de
desaparecer estos universitarios están
advirtiendo que saldrán a las calles
cada día
la nación vive envuelta en protestas
desde la muerte de la joven maxa aminy
de 22 años fallecida en custodia
policial el 16 de septiembre luego de
ser arrestada por la policía de la moral
la razón supuestamente llevar el velo
demasiado suelto mientras las fuerzas
del gobierno continúan la mortal
represión el líder supremo de Irán hizo
una poco usual aparición pública este
lunes alija menetildo de incidente
amargo la muerte de la joven y culpó a
fuerzas extranjeras de alentar las
protestas sí un perro
digo claramente que estos disturbios e
inseguridad Fueron diseñados por los
Estados Unidos y el ocupador y falso
régimen sionista así como por sus
agentes a sueldo con ayuda de traidores
iraníes en el extranjero
entre tanto a pesar de los intentos del
gobierno iraní de cortar internet siguen
apareciendo en redes sociales vídeos de
la violencia universitarios huyendo de
la policía de las pistolas de perdigones
y del gas lacrimógeno algunos intentan
huir adentro de un parqueadero pero son
atrapados y sacados con bolsas negras
sobre sus cabezas a pesar de la
represión informativa gubernamental
grupos de Derechos Humanos estiman que
decenas de personas han sido asesinadas
por la policía durante las protestas
y en Estados Unidos iniciaron este lunes
los alegatos en el juicio contra cinco
miembros del grupo de extrema derecha
ozkeepers incluido su fundador stewards
los acusados se enfrentan cargos por
conspiración y sedición por su
participación en el asalto al Capitolio
del 6 de enero de 2021 conectamos ahora
con nuestro corresponsal en Washington
Cristóbal Vázquez Cristóbal Buenas
tardes para usted que se ha conocido hoy
en esta primera jornada de alegatos
se ha conocido que las versiones
iniciales de los los fiscales que acusan
a
roads líder de la milicias y cuatro
integrantes más de este grupo pues son
acusados ya formalmente en este juicio
que inició hoy de Conspiración sediciosa
Es decir de tratar de evitar la
transferencia del poder el 6 de enero se
dicen que hay dicen los que los fiscales
que acusan a estos integrantes de la
milicia que tienen pruebas suficientes
que demuestran Cómo durante semanas
antes del 6 de enero esto estos
integrantes se reunieron en Virginia en
Arlington y reunieron a muchos
integrantes más armados para tomar
acciones militares ese día sin embargo
los abogados de las de los milicianos
inculpados dicen que no son culpables es
decir no aceptan los cargos argumentando
que estos milicianos estaban esperando
una orden que el presidente del ex
presidente Donald Trump de decretar acta
de insurrección y que entonces bajo esta
acta de insurrección estos milicianos
habrían podido actuar de forma privada
usando estrategia militar precisamente
para que Donald Trump se quedase en el
poder lo que dicen juristas expertos
sobre el tema es que está argumento de
estar esperando el acta de insurrección
por parte de un presidente no habilita
un grupo tercero un grupo militar
privado de tomar la justicia por las
manos o de actuar de forma privada
militarmente y además hay muchas pruebas
de espías sobre todo que indican que
pues en conversaciones después del 6 de
enero este estuvo habría dicho que si
hubiera tenido rifles si hubiera tomado
el Capitolio
Cristóbal Seguiremos muy de cerca este
proceso pero abordemos ahora otra
noticia judicial del día en Estados
Unidos y es que empezó el nuevo periodo
de sesiones de Suprema Cuáles son los
temas en la agenda de este nuevo año
judicial
pues un día histórico hoy en Estados
Unidos en Washington porque la primera
mujer afroamericana Pues en hace parte
de los nuevos integrantes de los nueve
magistrados de la Corte Suprema de
Justicia sin embargo hace parte de una
minoría liberal apenas tres magistrados
son de corte liberal versus los seis de
corte conservador que recientemente
formaron esta mayoría y entonces pues
ese ese ese input que va a tener que
tangible en este grupo de liberales va a
ser muy poco significativo y muy poco
significativo en cuatro temas
principales primero en Pues el alcance
que va a tener la agencia de protección
ambiental en cuanto a las aguas que no
están en terreno Federal el otro tema
importante será el tema de los derechos
de los votantes y de las leyes
electorales para las minorías también
está el tema de los Derechos LG LG de
los derechos de homosexuales se ve el
lgtbi también y también el tema de la
acción afirmativa serán cuatro temas muy
importantes que se tratarán en este
nueva sesión de la Corte Suprema acá en
Estados Unidos que va desde hoy hasta
enero Cristóbal Muchísimas gracias por
el reporte Buenas tardes para usted
y cambiamos de información el secretario
de estado de Estados Unidos Anthony
blinken inició este lunes su gira por
América Latina el funcionario llegó hoy
a Colombia donde adelanta una agenda
política que comenzó con una reunión con
el presidente Gustavo Petro un encuentro
que se espera que gira en torno a la
migración la crisis climática y el
narcotráfico recordemos que ante la
asamblea general de Naciones Unidas
Petro reprochó a Washington que su
guerra contra las drogas fracasó y que
es necesario un cambio de paradigma tras
su paso por Bogotá el secretario de
estado de Estados Unidos viajará a Chile
y a Perú
vamos con información de Brasil porque a
pesar de quedar en segundo lugar por
detrás de Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva el
actual mandatario Yahir bolsonaro salió
reforzado de las elecciones de ayer el
presidente no solo obtuvo un mejor
resultado del que anticipaban las
encuestas sino que su partido liberal se
convirtió en la primera fuerza en el
legislativo
mientras sus seguidores encomendaban a
Dios durante el recuento de votos Yair
bolsonaro obtuvo el domingo pese a su
segundo puesto en la primera vuelta una
importante Victoria Por una parte el
presidente brasileño obtuvo unos
resultados mejores de los que
pronosticaba las encuestas en su carrera
la reelección pero su Victoria
legislativa fue otro de sus grandes
alivios en su cita con las urnas la
nación Sudamericana renovaba los 513
asientos de su cámara de diputados y un
tercio de los 81 escaños del senado el
partido liberal la formación del
ultraderechista logró hacerse con 99
asientos frente a los 80 escaños que
obtuvo la federación de partidos de
izquierda de lulada Silva en el senado
un paisaje semejante con los liberales
de ultraderecha marcando la Pauta con la
mayoría además bolsonaro logró que
figuras polémicas de su entorno lograran
escaños como el exministro de salud de
Eduardo pasuelo criticado por su gestión
de la pandemia el ex titular de medio
ambiente Ricardo sales famoso por su
desmantelamiento de los órganos de
control ambiental o Sergio Moro el juez
que encarceló a Lula da Silva las
expectativas del presidente ya eran
altas al inicio de la jornada
expectativa de Victoria hoy teniendo en
cuenta los resultados en un momento
difícil para el país en general y en
estos 45 días de campaña ganamos en
prácticamente todos los estados de
Brasil y los recibimos muy bien pese a
todo las encuestas de cara al balotaje
siguen dando una mayoría al candidato
del partido de los trabajadores que se
comprometió a reforzar su campaña las
próximas semanas
es lo siguiente la lucha continúa hasta
la victoria final Ese es nuestro lema si
lo la gana Eso sí deberá enfrentarse a
un poderoso legislativo opositor que no
se lo pondrá nada fácil un congreso
mayoritariamente ultraconservador blanco
y masculino
y hoy el Instituto carolinska otorgó el
Nobel de Medicina 2022 al genetista
sueco svante pavo los descubrimientos de
pavo permitieron secuenciar el ADN
neardental comprender las migraciones de
homínidos prehistóricos y entender las
diferencias de los humanos modernos con
nuestros antepasados nuestra
especialista en ciencia y salud más
Romero sala nos cuenta más
la genética es una ventana nuestro
pasado más antiguo y nadie lo sabe mejor
que es bante pavo el científico sueco
galardonado con el premio Nobel de
medicina o fisiología de 2022
una vida de investigación la valido el
título de Padre de una nueva disciplina
la paleogenética el estudio del ADN de
especies extintas pero al recibir la
llamada del instituto carolinska todavía
pensó que le estaban tomando el pelo
al principio pensé que era una broma de
mi equipo
luego escuché que sonaba un poco
demasiado en serio
el científico desarrolló la primera
técnica para secuenciar ADN de decenas
de miles de años de antigüedad algo que
se creía imposible por el daño del paso
del tiempo
no solo sirve para la evolución humana
sirve para investigar muchos otros
grupos para estudiar muchos organismos
como las plantas animales extintos
patógenos Así que hace posible observar
la evolución en tiempo real
en 2010 secuencia por primera vez un ADN
de un neandertal y descubrió una nueva
especie de homínidos los denisovanos
gracias a pavo sabemos que los
neandertales y los Homo Sapiens se
reprodujeron mientras coexistían y que
en nuestro ADN hay pequeños porcentajes
de genética de los denisovanos y de los
neandertales herencias que hoy en día
explican por ejemplo que el sistema
inmune de algunas personas reaccionen
mejor o peor contra el Kobe 19 que
tengan más o menos riesgo de desarrollar
artritis o detener el colesterol alto
pero sobre todo es una herencia que
explica de dónde venimos los humanos y
cómo Hemos llegado hasta aquí
sigan con nosotros
[Música]